il existe un piège d'ouverture contre la
carocane hyper intéressant dans lequel
même le grand Gary Kasparov est tombé à
son apogé lorsqu'il affrontait la
machine 10 est dans cette position très
théorique on joue cavalier G5 pour créer
des thèmes sur case blanche et si les
Noirs jouent le tenton H6 ils se
prennent le terrible cavalier E6 prendre
est impossible à cause du mat de
l'imbécile et si la dame bouge on va au
final gagner la paire de fou avec les
Blancs et déjà obtenir un bon petit
avantage d'ouverture la partie se
poursuit donc par cavalier F6 on se
développe E6 cavalier F3 et de nouveau
H6 est une faute et c'est le coup joué
par Kasparov puisque ça permet à di blue
de balancer cavalier pr E6 c'est
terrible si les Noirs prennent on joue
simplement fou G6 échec roi E7 on rock
et derrière la partie est hyper facile
le roi noir est bien trop faible les
pièces désorganisées casasp va tenté
dame 7 sauf qu'après petit rock il ne
peut pas prendre de la dame à cause du
clouage et donc sur F prend fou G6 échec
c'est la même chose il a perdu en
seulement 19 coups à partir de là